ja ja doch ja aber die jetzt zehn uhr
abends vielleicht gerade schlafen in
einem nachtrag reinbekommen trader city
und die frage ob durch baukastens auf
dem kanal zu zeigen ja grundsätzlich
schon okay ist wenn man hochladen leute
heute zwei stunden wie soll ich das
schaffen allein mitschneiden
ja und genau so ist das ganze quasi
passiert also ich war wirklich gerade
dabei irgendwie mich fertig zu machen
und dann hat mich mein manager ja
einfach angerufen meinte so ob ich bock
hätte noch ein video zu machen
hey ihr sicherlich gerade in meinem bett
und das ganze ist auch eine kooperation
mit reggae deswegen steht hier oben
irgendwo werbevideo eingebildet habe ich
würde sagen gestürzt uns einfach mal
direkt ins game ich bekomme hier sehr
viele anzeigen immer wenn ich das spiel
startete und ihr seht auch schon jetzt
gerade hier ich habe schon mega viel am
start und unter anderem 60 millionen
gold das haben die filter weise einfach
mal so gegeben ihr wisst glaube ich dass
ich nicht so dafür bekannt windspiele
gut zu können
das ist die aufgabe von anderen also ich
bin eigentlich eher so der lupe ich habe
ehrlich gesagt nicht so eine grosse
ahnung worum es in diesem spiel geht
allerdings werden wir es jetzt einfach
mal zusammen entdecken die sich links am
rand die ziele eingeblendete mehr
drauflegen seht ihr schon kämpfen mit
einem drachen gewinnen die a1 einen
großen bauernhof und für jedes ziel
bekommen wir ja quasi xp gold erdbeer
und ever erdbeeren
ich hab so unnormal woche fährt werden
gerade wissen dass hier der mitte sieht
er ein schwede
vielen dank fürs ansehen hier ist eine
belohnung okay das ist super cool danke
dann gib mir den mal ich hab ja auch
erst 33.000 von den teilen wir machen
jetzt einfach mal dass hier tempo mit
deinen drachen trainiere du wirst keine
verlierende los also es ist sehr geil
dass ich keine drachen verlieren werde
ich kann jetzt irgendwie aus wie in dem
beispielsweise halo gastón und wallace
und legt dann auch okay meint reihe halo
gegen die natur drachen natur drache der
name ist super kreativ ich kann jetzt
hier unten zwischen vier verschiedenen
attacken aus wir nehmen beispielsweise
nach einer energie weil ich weiß dass
diese attacke eine menge ab zieht
nämlich so 4000 immer und jetzt gerade
genau drei 1988 und es einfach ins den
tod jetzt kommt der zweite das ist ein
löwenzahn rache und zwar für seinen
löwenzahn drache disneys operator wir
werden jetzt beispielsweise mal nicht
sterben an wurzbach 1070 tod so eine
schwache attacke tötet den gegner
übrigens sorry dass ich hier gerade mein
bett liege aber ihr habt jetzt zu beginn
schon gesehen
es ist gerade wirklich ultras spät und
hat jetzt keinen bock noch am pc zu
setzen deswegen zog ich das ganze hier
quasi gerade mit kabel an meinem laptop
das ist jetzt ein feuervogel drache das
heißt nicht wechsel jetzt einmal meinen
drachen zu beispielsweise diesem
eiswürfel wallace und ich glaube der
müsste die gegen dem wasser attacke am
und seiner stadt ist schwach kritisch
oder fax meiner meinung nach wenn ich
jetzt einfach mal zum namen ihrer und
das ist sehr sehr kritisch weil das ist
ein feuer genau
tisch 4110 tot doch vor und migros hat
dir der kampf gefallen wir hoffen es um
weiterzukämpfen trittin liegen bei oder
erreicht die stufe 10 und hoffe das
kolosseum im shop ich habe 100 gold
erhalten und 150 xp das ist natürlich
sehr leid von das nächste ziel ist liga
eins gewinnen ich würde sagen das machen
wir
ich spiele jetzt gerade online ich packe
manche jetzt einfach mal halo parsifal
und in rain okay da krieg ich auch okay
und jetzt kann ich mir glauben falsch
ist weil sie ihn mir aussuchen und gegen
jetzt maria solo ging wenn special
kämpfen wahrscheinlich hat er 19.000
kaffee und macht mich direkt rot okay
ich kann eines direkt schlafen mit dem
kissen aus dem super shop dann nehme ich
jetzt meinen zweiten drachen bauen hier
rein werde kopfstoß an und das zieht ihm
genau 2700 ab er macht seinen flug
wahrscheinlich bin ich tot
ja kann ich nicht mal gewinnen ich will
den letzten drachen gar nicht mehr
nehmen überhaupt hey fangen wir mal film
rain man bei yukos fühlt sich mein
vielleicht
wenigstens noch besiegen sieht wieder
nur 2400 erwarte jetzt nicht mehr locker
14.000 ab nämlich 12.000 und ich bin tot
und habe sieht man ihm wurde ist
verloren hat aber leute ich hab voll
viel stuff von den entwicklern bekommen
also gold diamanten alles mögliche
deswegen pump ich das jetzt alles in
meine drachenreiter klicken auf party
fall drauf bitte an denen einfach mal
und dann hoffe ich dass er gleich gegen
krasic level ist so dass wir die anderen
sieben soll nun da hat die maximale
stufe erreicht er kann beim aussteigen
in einen tempel im laden kaufen case
stufe 30 schauen ob ich noch ein tempel
kaufen kann nämlich der nächste tempel
ist erst bei stufe 40
da scheue ich heute wahrscheinlich nicht
mehr ich level jetzt mal eben meine
anderen drachen auch noch ein bisschen
hoch und dann sehen wir uns im nächsten
kampf wider
ich habe jetzt drei drachen auf level 30
deswegen gehe ich jetzt einfach mal
wieder hier auf gewinne liege 1 liter
auf los stelle mir mein team zusammen
und das besteht jetzt nämlich auf party
falco und nessi klick auf ok und suche
mir jetzt beispielsweise diesen krippen
hier mal aus ok direkt 3500 abgezogen
aber ich werde es einfach mal
beteiligenden schlag aus sieben 5300 ab
und das ist wirklich ein ausgeglichener
kampf hier so ein bisschen dass man sich
wirklich gegenseitig die ganze das ab
zieht er ist droht so jetzt kommt sein
zweites monster da wenn ich jetzt mal
beispielsweise die erste attacke eben an
aufschlag direkt auf cakl strauch mal
schauen wie viel das sieht 4800 nicht
direkt tot aber ich hoffe erfüllt mich
jetzt nicht direkt am rathaus sondern
das heißt es reicht noch für einmal
lichtschwert gegen credits und parsifal
ist gerade gestorben das heißt ich packe
jetzt mal lässt ihre einmal lässt sie
sieht ultra geil aus mach jetzt seine
lama attacke und glaube dass sie sogar
sehr stark ist nämlich 5000 ich zerstöre
den jetzt komplett in gegner brand teile
die fresse von roger den meerjungfrauen
drachen 4300 bekommt er abgezogen und er
ist tot
ich habe gewonnen insofern ich das jetzt
richtig verstanden habe geht es also
nimmt spiel darum dass man immer ein
höheres level erreicht und das erreicht
man halt dadurch indem man mehr und
maccambes online oder offline gegen
andere leute man pusht seine drachen
hoch füttert die trainiert die und ich
bin es eigentlich echt ganz cool es ist
jetzt natürlich blöd gewesen ist die
anfrage relativ spontan kamen und ich
jetzt halt gerade abends in meinem bett
liege nicht mehr komplett fit bin ich
hoffe euch hat das video irgendwie
gefallen ich habe mir einfach gedacht
kate ist eine mega spontane anfrage
jetzt gerade gewesen aber auf der
anderen seite ultra coolen welt einfach
das geld von denen zocke und die haben
noch ein video mit einer nackten gaming
video also ist ja eigentlich eine win
win situation wenn euch das video hier
gefallen hat das gerne mein leib dar und
schreib doch mal auch in die kommentare
unten was eure scorten bei dragon city
mit dem hashtag dragon luca